no I'm not kevin rudd sorry to
disappoint you but he'll be here
momentarily after my brief remarks and
after a brief introduction by a couple
of our Australian students my name is
Jared Cohen I'm the president Carnegie
Mellon and it's a great pleasure to
welcome you to this very special
occasion we're very honored to have with
us today the Australian Prime Minister
Kevin Rudd traveling with him today is
his wife to raise rain was also a
clinical psychologist he's also also
with him is the Honorable Wayne Swan the
treasure of australia and the Honorable
Dennis Richardson Australian Australia's
ambassador to United States of course as
we know a prime minister is here to
attend the g20 event which will be
opening just a few minutes after he
finishes speaking here among the g20
countries Australia stands out for us
here at Carnegie Mellon in terms of the
relationship we enjoy with the country
we have 58 students from Australia I
would have expected that would get a
cheer from the Australian students our
hines college as a campus in adelaide in
the state of a state of South Australia
a program that opened in 2006 at the
time we were the first foreign
university ever to be granted the
permission to offer its own degree
programs and sewn degree in Australia an
honor that we appreciate very much since
then we've graduated more than 130
students who have gone on to have a big
impact in Australia and in the other
countries they're from I want to take
this opportunity to thank the Prime
Minister and his government for their
outstanding support especially a really
admirable program that Australia has
called us aid scholarships which allows
students from developing countries to
study at australian universities in even
carnegie mellon university in australia
i also want to take the opportunity to
thank the government of south australia
and its premier mike rann who's
in our great supporter from from the
beginning what we're doing in Adelaide I
want you to know is something that lines
up very well with the Prime Minister's
of vision for what he calls world-class
public service in the 21st century he's
very committed to education as a way to
prepare public servants and something
that he sees is that requires attention
we're delighted to be part of that
vision a secondary in which australia
and carnegie mellon share strong
interest is robotics we consider there
to be three great field robotic centers
in the world two of them happened to be
in Australia the Australian Centre for
field robotics at the University of
Sydney and the CSIRO has an autonomous
systems laboratory at their ICT center
the third of course is here at Carnegie
Mellon the center founded by red
Whittaker the great robotics pioneer in
one that we're very very proud of those
two centers in Australia and ours here
enjoy a very warm relationship and
collaboration which is growing all the
time and finally a third area of common
interest is global warming and here I
want to take a moment to congratulate
the prime minister who's been among the
most outspoken and most forceful heads a
government in the world when it comes to
global warming and unlike the heads of
most governments in the world he has
made actual commitments something I
think we should all be grateful for his
leadership has had a big impact in area
of particular interest to Australia is
carbon capture and sequestration an area
that we're especially strong in here and
in fact our colleague at Rubin was the
lead author on the carbon sequestration
chapter in the IPCC report that received
the nobel peace prize in which he shared
for all these reasons were especially
pleased to have the prime minister with
us today I hope most of you will be able
to stay for the distinguished panel
discussion that will be held right after
Prime Minister's speech a panel
discussion on the topic of globalization
technology innovation and the economy
and now to introduce the prime minister
and please introduce to you Matthew
Craig graduate student in the Heinz
college and Patrick Burke a graduate
student in engineering gentlemen please
Carnegie Mellon is a truly global
university with connections than the
lamb nigh across the world one of the
most significant connection is in my
hometown of Adelaide in Australia in
2006 Carnegie Mellon with the support of
the australian government and the south
australian government established Hines
College Australia now Australia has a
long history of pragmatic and socially
responsible public policy and the Heinz
college is an excellent fit there and
the relationship has benefited both in
fact it's this relationship which has
brought me here today I arrived here
just four weeks ago after studying at
the Australian campus since 2008 and I
was attracted to the University by the
reputation of the University but also by
the way that this education could
benefit my local community while
studying I've also been working with the
South Australian Government and seen
firsthand how directly relevant and
beneficial the Carnegie Mellon
experiences to Australia I've also seen
the benefit to Carnegie Mellon by
expanding its reach and attracting new
students from around the world now this
relationship between Carnegie Mellon and
Australia is closed it's expanding all
the time and ultimately it's what's
brought the prime minister here to speak
to us today like many here I was
initially attracted to Carnegie Mellon
based on this institution's reputation
in computer science and engineering
fields that in recent decades have
profoundly changed the world in which we
live during my time here however I have
witnessed that same drive to innovate
not only in the areas in which Carnegie
Mellon presently stands proud but those
that will profoundly impact the world in
future decades many of the people here
are the best in the world at what they
do but more than that i'm often struck
by their sense of community and
willingness to work with others both
within and outside their own areas of
expertise and around the world indeed
this was very clearly demonstrated to me
when shortly after coming to Carnegie
Mellon coming email and came to a
delayed opening one of several new
campuses worldwide
it is such interdisciplinary approaches
and a strong desire to cooperate that we
must bring to bear if we have to resolve
many of the issues being discussed this
week we are fortunate in today's keynote
address to hear from Prime Minister the
Prime Minister of Australia mr. Kevin
Rudd possesses a unique perspective on
these issues Mr Rudd was elected the
26th Prime Minister of Australia in
November 2007 and has been a vocal
advocate for the environment education
and global cooperation it is my pleasure
to introduce on behalf of the Australian
and the entire Carnegie Mellon community
the Prime Minister of Australia the
Honorable mr. Kevin Rudd
thank you very much that very warm
welcome and to dr. Cohen president of
Carnegie Mellon University and mrs.
Cohen mr. Tim McNulty associate vice
president for government relations dr.
Randy Bryant Dean the School of Computer
Science other members of the faculty and
staff dr. Amaya Krishna and Dean of the
Heinz college and Hines College
Australia students and faculty of
Carnegie Mellon and if I could thank
from the outset the Pittsburgh and
Carnegie Mellon communities for their
support for this event thank you for
this warm invitation to this great city
and to this great University this is my
first time to Pittsburgh this is my
first time to this University so as a
very proud self-proclaimed nerd i sat
down last night to google a little about
what I was about to come and discover
over here in Pittsburgh and knowing that
I'd be speaking to a room full of nerds
I thought you'd appreciate that it's now
250 years unadvised since the British
ordered the construction of Fort Pitt at
the forks of the I Ohio River in
November of 1758 naming a settlement
between the rivers Pittsburgh which in
time of course became Pittsburgh and it
was George Washington himself who only
five years before then recommended the
junctions of these rivers and I quote
him well situated for a fort and
Washington with an early and keen eye
for real estate observed it was and I
quote him again very convenient for
building of course it was in these parts
that major Washington began his military
career in the French and Indian War
before subsequently rising to the
generalship of the Continental Army and
following a success of the Revolutionary
War to the presidency of the infant
Republic had Washington being less
successful in his military exploits out
here in the 1750s it's worth pondering
whether the Continental Congress would
have turned to him to lead the
Continental Army twenty years later an
absent Washington's generalship with the
American revolutionaries have ever
prevailed you do toughen them up out
here in the western parts of
Pennsylvania but with a local football
team
called the Pittsburgh Steelers would you
expect anything less these were
momentous times in America's history
momentous times which shape not only
your own country's future but also
indirectly my country as well for once
Washington had prevailed over Cornwallis
at Yorktown the British lost their
American colonies as a dumping ground
for British convicts and so instead your
mind has raised a head I can tell and so
instead set about identifying an
alternative and appropriate piece of
real estate to deal with the detritus of
the British justice system and so was
born the new convict settlement of
Sydney its main street Pitt Street
bearing the same name as the city in
both cases deriving from the great
political dynasty of the same name
that's so comprehensively dominated mid
Georgian British politics of course the
moral of the story is simple we should
all blame the British for everything
of course had Washington been less
successful in the Revolutionary War my
own criminal forebears would probably
have ended up in these colonies rather
than in Australian but as President
Clinton remarked to me earlier this week
one of the clear delineating lines
between the settle history of Australia
and America is that America got the
Puritans and Australia got the criminals
although the president said he was still
wondering who got the better deal think
about it this great University Carnegie
Mellon also happens to be as old as the
Commonwealth of Australia itself founded
in nineteen hundred by the great
industrialist Andrew Carnegie this
university has grown to become one of
the great American universities
recognized for its world-class Arts and
Technology programs Carnegie Mellon has
become a global research university of
more than 4,000 faculty staff 10,000
students and seventy thousand alumni
Carnegie Mellon also as has been
mentioned today operate in Adelaide
South Australia and is already making a
great contribution to higher education
in Australia and that I presume that
poster over there of Andrew Carnegie is
what he looks like from Down Under I had
to ask what it was when I came in the
university prides itself on its
innovation and as a result has written
for itself a large place in America's
future this university and so many
respects embodies Pittsburgh's Tale of
Two Cities it was Andrew Carnegie who
began the steel industry in the 1870s
making Pittsburgh for the next hundred
years of steel capital of America and
the world but the truth of economic
policy of economic history is that
nothing ever stays the same nothing ever
stand still as the steel industry began
to close down during the last quarter
century it was Carnegie's University
rather than his steel company which
provided a transformational vehicle for
the old city of heavy industry to become
the new city of the future one grounded
in the globalizing knowledge economy of
the 21st century
Pittsburgh is therefore not just famous
for its place in economic history but
also for the transformation it has
undergone to secure its economic future
nobody should underestimate how tough
the job of transformation has been for a
city like Pittsburgh my advisors tell me
that watching the Steelers the Penguins
and the Pirates play their respective
sports which I'm reliably informed in
this order our football hockey and
baseball you have the privilege of
seeing right up close and personal the
spirit of this city on very physical and
public display by the way we in
Australia do appreciate our contact
sport as well so we have no problems
with that but I doubt that any culture
or city on earth could compete with a
city such as this that could boast the
Steelers the Penguins and the Pirates on
the one hand an Andy Warhol Gene Kelly
and Perry Como on the other Florence eat
your heart out this is the Australian
idea of a truly Renaissance setting the
people of Pittsburgh have demonstrated
themselves to be resilient adaptable and
creative the city is in many respects
our living essay for the capacity of
America as a nation to constantly
reinvent itself to be in a permanent
state of self-renewal the city is known
instinctively that you cannot insulate
yourself from change because no City no
country and no economy can ever do that
it's also why cities like Pittsburgh
have a message for America and for the
world as they confront the new wave of
fundamental change to sweeping across
the globe in the form of climate change
and specifically the ideas the systems
and the technologies that the global
economy will need to adapt to this
existential economic and environmental
threat that confronts our common future
but the core challenge is essentially
the same namely there's how to convert
adversity into opportunity how to
convert threat into possibility and how
to deploy the technologies which now lie
within our reach and the finance
necessary to deploy them not only to
deal with climate change but
also to create the new skills the new
jobs and the new industries for the
American and global economies of the
21st century and it is on this subject
that I wish to address my remarks today
this afternoon on the eve of the g20
summit the major economies of the world
are gathering here in Pittsburgh their
agenda is broad but essentially goes to
two sets of fundamental threats to our
common future the global financial
crisis as well as the looming crisis
that is climate change it is fitting
therefore that we meet in Pittsburgh
because both these crises represent
transformational opportunities for the
future transformational opportunities
for the world just as you have succeeded
in transforming this great city for the
global financial crisis the challenge is
to respond creatively to the systemic
risks we have confronted over the last
12 months not to assume we will simply
return to a business as usual approach
but as a global economic system to
embrace fundamental economic and
financial regulatory reforms to secure
our collective economic future we need
to reform the rules of the financial
system we need to reform the
institutions of global financial and
economic governance more broadly we need
to reform the institutions of wider
global economic governance we must now
develop a sustainable growth strategy
for the long-term not just to better
coordinate macroeconomic policy for the
future better macroeconomic coordination
to prevent the re-emergence of the
unsustainable global imbalances that
fuel the global crisis and that has seen
tens of millions of working families
across the world lose their jobs but
beyond avoiding another crisis our
parallel challenge is this how to
generate the economic growth and the
jobs of the future given that the dead
driven consumption model the past is
unlikely to be trusted anymore because
if we fail to find a new growth model we
face the prospect of lower global growth
and less jobs for the future in other
words a global growth cap which absent
other growth generators could be as
large as six trillion dollars out of a
global economy of 63 trillion
US dollars the numbers suggest therefore
that this is a central economic problem
not a marginal economic problem and a
central economic problem for us all so
what therefore will the new platform for
global growth be for the future to begin
with a successful conclusion of the
global free trade round is one obvious
candidate a result which the Peterson
Institute is calculated could produce
750 billion dollars worth of additional
global GDP a second possibility is the
great wave of global productivity growth
and new business development that will
come from the digital revolution which
is one reason why the australian
government is now as a part of our
fiscal stimulus strategy to deal with
the global recession now laying out a
national high-speed broadband network at
100 megabits per second to ninety
percent of our country fiber-optic to
the premises fiber-optic to the home to
help turbocharged our economy through
the 21st century a third real
possibility for global growth and jobs
of the future is the transformation of
the global economy to a lower carbon
future in other words to turn the threat
of climate change into a great
transformational economic opportunity at
pittsburg the g20 will deal with how to
transform the global economy to a lower
carbon world through carbon markets
global finance both public and private
and the technology platforms necessary
to give effect to global commitments to
cut greenhouse gas emissions climate
change indeed represents a great
long-term threat to our planet the
agreed science warns us that the impact
from climate change will be a clear
threat to nations by 2020 between 75 and
250 million people in Africa could be
exposed to climate change induced water
shortages rain-fed agriculture yields
may drop by up to fifty percent in some
African countries by 2050 rising sea
levels could directly affect more than 1
million people in the river delta
regions of Bangladesh Vietnam and Egypt
sea levels could rise by a meter or more
over three feet by 2100 if the world
does not act by the year
2100 global temperatures could rise by
up to six point four degrees Celsius
that's more than 10 degrees Fahrenheit
these impacts will be felt right across
the world no respecter of Nations no
respecter of peoples definitionally a
global challenge demanding a global
response but in areas like the Pacific
Ocean where many small island states sit
only meters above the sea level the
impacts will be more immediate and more
devastating without global action the
economic impacts of climate change will
be substantial Nicholas stone found that
doing nothing to address climate change
will result in costs equivalent to
reducing economic welfare by between
five and twenty percent per person now
and forever what does all this mean it
means first and foremost that we the
community of nations must act there is
an overwhelming environmental and
economic urgency to act on climate
change what we need to do is limit the
amount of carbon getting into the
atmosphere according to the four
thousand member international panel on
climate change scientists one of whom I
had the great privilege of meeting here
this evening a distinguished member of
your faculty its panel's report agreed
to by all governments concluded that we
need to stabilize the concentration of
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere at
450 parts per million or lower and we
need to take action to limit the rise in
temperatures to less than 2 degrees
Celsius our response as a community of
nations and as the economies of the
world must be grounded in the science we
will only be able to achieve our
objective if we act collectively to move
to lower carbon economies this move will
require decisive action based by real
leadership and founded on strong science
we need the right international and
national agreements we need the right
mechanism to finance the transition and
we need to develop and deploy the best
technology to affect that transition the
foundation of all this is establishing
the carbon markets to ensure emissions
reductions are achieved more effective
more efficiently we need to get the
International systems in place to enable
this hour
to do that we need to make sure that we
get a positive result from the United
Nations Copenhagen meeting in December
in the lead-up to the meeting we need to
use every path at our disposal to build
the international consensus and lead up
to that conference we also need to take
big decisions many of which only leaders
can take we need to take every
opportunity to take the discussion
forward where we have leaders gathered
together in one place at one time we did
that at the major economies forum
meeting in Italy in July and we need to
do that again over the next day or so
here in Pittsburgh on top of
international agreements we also need
each of us to put a price on carbon
putting a price on carbon will create
incentives to move to lower emitting
activities including an energy
generation for Australia we have
designed a carbon pollution reduction
scheme aim to do just that our objective
is to have our scheme passed by the
Australian Parliament before the
Copenhagen meeting we believe that
nations should go to Copenhagen not just
with targets but with the means to
achieve those targets as well the key
idea is that international action and
domestic action must be linked to ensure
that we actually deliver the results the
emissions reductions that are needed
greenhouse gas reductions do not occur
because we sign an international
agreement greenhouse gas reductions
occur because of the action then taken
on the ground the finance then deployed
and the technology then deployed the
rules also need to be laid out now
because investment decisions in the
energy sector and the rest of the
economy are long-term business certainty
also demands we settle the rules of
national carbon markets rapidly and then
take action to link markets as rapidly
as possible across the world furthermore
as the French president reminded us
publicly this week at the United Nations
failure to adopt carbon markets will
result in real pressure to impose
retaliatory tariffs environmental
tariffs to those countries that have or
from those countries that have
climate change will have a real economic
and financial cost as with any cost it
has to be borne by someone climate
finance is a critical piece of the
global climate change solution we all
agree that developed ikot economies and
developed countries need to commit to
concrete emissions reduction but they
will only commit to the ambitious
targets we need to keep greenhouse gas
concentrations to below 450 parts per
million if they know that emerging
economies are prepared to play their
part in reducing emissions but without
financial support for transitional
arrangements for the world's poorest
countries emerging economies have
indicated that they cannot make
commitments to climate change action
each of these elements is integral to a
global deal at Copenhagen without
climate finance both public and private
through carbon markets emerging
economies will not agree to verifiable
commitments to reduce their emissions
and if emerging economies fail the
shoulder they're part of the future
burden developed economies are unlikely
to agree to binding targets themselves
that is why in my address to the United
Nations General Assembly last night I
argued for a grand bargain between
developed and developing countries and
economies at Copenhagen linking targets
and commitments with finance and
technology we do not know yet what it
will all look like this deal this
agreement we will need to keep doing the
hard policy work over the next seventy
three days to Copenhagen to work towards
a solution on this question I hope that
the meetings this week both here and the
United Nations in New York will provide
some of the political direction needed
to drive this work along so far I have
spoken about policy that will reduce
national emissions and policy that will
provide the financing to lock a deal
into place but in Pittsburgh and here at
Carnegie Mellon University i also want
to speak about technology i've just seen
your Oh bollocks lab and some of the
cutting-edge research that's going on
and some of the potential applications
to climate change some of the potential
applications to greenhouse gas emissions
and they're monitoring it is innovation
of this caliber that
we are going to need to tackle climate
change effectively climate change is
caused by human activity that human
activity has been driven by technology
and technology will be a key part of the
human activity that is now necessary to
reduce climate change by less
carbon-intensive energy generation and
by energy efficiency in which there will
be a large part of the solution had as
well we can do things more efficiently
but we are not going to turn off the
need for energy developed in developing
countries alike need energy they need of
their economic development they need it
for the lives of their citizens the
dilemma therefore we face is how do we
reduce energy use and make energy
cleaner energy efficiency potentially
represents thirty percent of the total
greenhouse gas reductions we will need
for the future this is a big number
energy efficiency therefore represents
an equally large potential generator of
new jobs in high-tech in medium tech and
even in lower tech or no tech
labor-intensive work as well energy
efficiency covers a wide spectrum of
industry possibilities including the
fuel efficiency of cars smart grids and
meters at home and at the office proper
home installation to reduce heating and
cooling needs for example the physical
stimulus strategy we are deploying in
Australia at present to counter the
global recession aims to ensure that
every owner occupied dwelling in
Australia has ceiling insulation a three
billion dollar plus program that aims to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions by up to
50 million tons and on the way through
create thousands of low-skilled jobs for
people suffering from the recession we
are also using these temporary jobs to
add on new training programs to obscure
workers for employment elsewhere once
this fiscal program is complete we also
have to use energy more efficiently
including in our buildings this is not
just about turning off the lights when
you leave a room though that's important
it's about the way buildings are
designed how they are built in how they
are operated in Australia we expect
dioxide emissions from commercial
buildings to increase by one hundred and
fifty percent out to 2050 if we do not
take any policy actions given that this
sector makes up ten percent of our total
greenhouse gas emissions change here
really matters what we have to do is set
standards at the national level to make
buildings more energy-efficient it is in
part about mandating minimum energy
efficiency standards for new buildings
we have to make energy efficiency a core
part of building design across the world
but is also about running buildings more
efficiently to get more energy efficient
buildings we will need a combination of
tougher standards and innovative design
and engineering solutions you have some
great examples of what can be achieved
right here in Pittsburgh I understand
that the David L Lawrence Convention
Center where we will gather for the g20
summit tomorrow is the largest certified
green building in the world and that the
Pittsburgh region has the highest
concentration of green buildings in the
country these are good things to be able
to talk about these are great
achievements by this local community
internationally the United States is
taking the lead under President Obama in
this area in the major economies forum
he did so when he chaired that forum in
Italy in July and with a scientist of
the global standing of energy secretary
Steve Chu as a key player in driving
this work and cities like Pittsburgh are
taking a lead I'm sure that we will see
real progress in the future but let us
be clear energy efficiency is one of the
great transformational economic
opportunities for the future critical to
bring down emissions critical critical
also for the generation of new jobs and
new industries for the future but even
if we have the most efficient buildings
we are still going to need energy in
2006 renewable energy met only seven
percent of global primary energy needs
according to the International Energy
Agency by 2050 forty six percent of
global power will need to come from
renewable if we are to meet our target
of stabilizing global greenhouse gas
emissions at 450 parts per million by
then
that renewable energy can come from a
variety of sources to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions we need to increase our
overall use of each of these sources
there is wide recognition of the need to
get on with this and to get on with it
now and there's wide recognition also
the opportunities that this presents for
both developed and developing countries
China is one of the world leaders in
wind technology India has taken enormous
steps to create an attractive investment
environment for the private sector to
invest in solar power it is estimated
that 120 billion US dollars was invested
in renewable energy worldwide in 2008
most of this goes to wind power and a
solar power the global capacity of wind
power is growing at around 30 percent
per year solar two is growing rapidly in
Australia we have just passed through
the parliament new renewable energy
target legislation that will ensure that
by 2020 twenty percent of Australia's
total electricity generation will come
from renewable sources we've also
committed over a billion dollars us to
support the construction of up to four
large-scale solar power stations to
connect to our energy grid a solar
project of up to 1,000 megawatts three
times larger than the current largest
solar power plant in the world in
California Australia does not lack for
sunshine we do not lack for land in fact
we do not lack for desert we intend to
get on with it we hope to be able to
think big on this question and to do
real things that count to demonstrate
the work that can be achieved on the
ground and the cost with which such
electricity can be delivered into the
grid what we must do across the world is
to continue to drive the innovation
share the knowledge about renewable
energy and to accelerate most critically
the deployment and to the greatest
extent possible we need to turn
renewable energy into both a global
public good and a new large generator of
business and employment opportunity the
welcome increase in renewable energy
does not mean that people will give up
on more traditional energy sources when
the cost of carbon pollution is factored
into our economies the cost-benefit
analysis changes for many energy sources
the reality is the world won't stop
using coal on the
contrary its share of total energy
production is projected to rise out to
2030 coal consumption is expected to
increase 61 percent between 2006 and
2030 so how do we deal with the
challenge of emissions from coal is
critical to how we deal overall with
climate change it cannot be ignored the
cue to maintaining coal is a viable
energy source is capturing and storing
the carbon dioxide that is produced when
coal is burned the International Energy
Agency estimates that nearly one-fifth
of the required emissions reductions
could come from carbon capture and
storage the technology exists but it is
new it can be expensive and requires
regulations to be put in place the
australian government decided last year
that we wanted to enable this technology
so we established the global carbon
capture and storage Institute the
Institute is tasked with helping realize
the goal of 20 large-scale carbon
capture and storage projects by which we
mean 500 megawatts and above in
operation by 2020 as committed to buy
the g8 at the hokkaido summit last year
it brings together in one place the key
technologies the expertise and the legal
and regulatory frameworks a project
register across the world and the
knowledge about financing to make these
projects happen its mandate is to make
carbon capture and storage happen and
happen globally its membership now
stands at 123 governments and
organizations including all 2020 of the
g20 major economies and all the major
energy companies in the world off the
northwest coast of Australia we have
some of the world's largest natural gas
reserves these reserves have the
potential to provide a clean form of
energy to customers around the world but
the extraction of the gas produces
carbon dioxide last week the Gorgon
joint venture including two American
companies with a long history of
developing Australian resources Chevron
and ExxonMobil announced that they would
build Australia's largest have a gas
project they also announced that in
order to reduce greenhouse gas emissions
from its latest expansion the naturally
occurring carbon dioxide contained in
the gas will be injected installed in a
reservoir more than 2,000 meters below
ground this is expected to be the
world's largest carbon dioxide injection
project it will be a commercial
gail demonstration of ccs technology and
will position Australia is a global
leader in CCS technology more broadly it
was made possible by the decision of the
Australian and Western Australian
Government's to actively support this
project carbon sequestration in fact was
a condition of the project imposed by
the government of Western Australia the
idea for our global carbon capture and
storage Institute is to identify other
projects around the world that can
demonstrate the various applications of
the technology across a range of
geological storage sites it will become
a repository for knowledge in all
relevant areas we see this as a genuine
Global Institute a global public good we
established it we manage it we are
largely funding it one hundred million
dollars per annum we don't own it but we
think the idea alive in this Institute
could be a useful model to help drive
not just CCS but help drive other key
climate change technologies as well
including each of the main categories of
renewable energy and even energy
efficiency such Institute's could pull
the best global knowledge in each field
they can be virtual rather than physical
to convert also the great enabling
client climate change technologies into
a combination of global public goods
while also supporting market signals
necessary to fuel innovation and
investment and perhaps we could even
have some public global competitive
pressure to help drive innovation
between governments and between
institutions if Australia seeks to be a
global leader on carbon capture and
storage drawing together a cooperative
consortium from around the world that's
encouraged other nations to step up to
the plate to lead similar global public
and private consortium in each of the
renewables in each of the main
technology areas and applications in
renewable energy and an energy
efficiency to solve the challenges in
developing and in deploying these
critical new technologies we will need
to drive the process forward and not
just wait for it to happen on climate
change we need to rapidly harness and
deploy these global public goods because
the clock is ticking too fast to
conclude your University here in
Pittsburgh is perhaps best known for its
science and technology but I appreciate
that the fact
staff here like the population of
Pittsburgh is more diverse than that I'd
like to put a challenge before all of
you the student body the faculty the
alumni and the business community of
this great city we need you all to
devote your talents to solving climate
change we need the financial experts the
academics and the practitioners to help
deliver the funding solutions we need we
need the lawyers to help develop the
legal and regulatory frameworks we need
the scientists and the engineers to do
the research and development the
technology to make the solutions work we
need you all to be innovators we need
policy innovation we need financial
innovation properly regulated of course
we need technical innovation we also
need political imagination political
imagination across the world to make
this financial and technological
revolution on climate change happen on
the ground and happen now you here in
Pittsburgh have a broad canvas to work
on and the scope to develop your own
solutions and now I know it's not fair
to ask people to do something without
offering up something yourself so I say
to you that I'll be doing my absolute
best here in Pittsburgh at the g20 and
Beyond and at every opportunity to lead
up to Copenhagen to help build the
political will and consensus necessary
to bring about a positive outcome for
the planet come December we have used
technology before to overcome problems
developments in genetics in the 1970s
led to the green revolution have allowed
us to feed a much more populated world
we've eradicated a number of deadly
diseases from the face of the earth
today we need the commitment personal
national and international to apply that
same dedication to tackling climate
change pittsburgh has recast itself
Pittsburgh did not bury its head in the
sand instead Pittsburgh rose to the
challenge of change now we need to apply
that same spirit of innovation
determination and enterprise across the
world to rise to the challenge of
climate change each one of you is
crucial to our combined success and I
ask you as I ask other leaders around
the world to join us in that challenge
as human beings we are capable of great
creativity just it was we are also
capable of great destruction it is time
to summon forth the bed
angels of our nature the challenge is
great and the time is short I thank
you